ellos también están presentes en la cob
26 quieren que el mundo sepa que sus
tierras están amenazadas muchos
indígenas son escépticos a las promesas
de los gobiernos de sus países de
proteger sus tierras utilizadas para
actividades extractivistas
recibimos más acaba de hablar el
presidente del ecuador habla de la
protección del cambio climático que el
ecuador está tiene su diversidad muy
grande pero es una mentira porque la
verdad no yo conozco desde la comunidad
de hemos venido desde el territorio y
hemos visto a hoy en día los gobiernos
tienen su plan de sacar el petróleo
otro indígena dice estar preocupado por
la contaminación de las vías fluviales
donde él y su familia viven en chile
en muy poco tiempo en los últimos 100
200 años la gente ha estado explorando
la profundidad de lugares que pensábamos
que aún estaban por descubrir había
personas cuidando esas tierras y ahora
están poniendo minas allí extrayendo el
litio y cosas que nos impiden seguir
viviendo allí en la cumbre climática los
líderes mundiales y jefes de estado se
comprometieron a proteger las
comunidades indígenas y las selvas
tropicales invirtiendo millonarias sumas
dinero con fondos públicos y privados
además para disminuir la deforestación
en esta década países que representan
más del 85% de los bosques del mundo se
comprometieron a detenerla entre ellos
varios de américa latina como brasil
colombia y perú sin embargo los
indígenas no están seguros de que estos
planes se vayan a cumplir y aseguran que
una vez implementada las nuevas promesas
habrá que ver el impacto total